oh my God
oh my god dude you happy
I mean yeah I guess I don't know what
you're asking me I didn't you look happy
yeah I'm pretty happy it's pretty funny
it's a very nice outfit
yeah
chicken tender platter yeah yeah full
platter with the fries full of fries
yeah that's what makes it better
[Music]
all you gotta do for me Beauty
hello welcome to dudesy my name is Will
Sasso
I'm Chad colchern this dude's the first
uh podcast controlled created by
conceived by written by an artificial
intelligence that has access to all of
our emails text messages purchase
histories watch histories listen
histories everything we do online and it
tailors the show specifically to
archimedic sensibilities this week
obviously dudes he made will dress up as
a chicken tender plant
huh
yeah dudesy caused some shots Chad what
the duty duty might decide this and that
with regard to what we do on the show
but the thing I want everyone to
understand is that you know yeah it's
two dudes [__] around we are doozy
you know what I'm saying you know and
the pods out there the pals of doozy
that's doozy it's a whole it's a whole
kind of dude's an idea it's like Batman
yeah Batman's a guy though so anyway
um go to more than a guy oh that's
pretty good is that your uh it's an idea
okay no this is my Werner Herzog go to
uh linktree.com doozy that's where you
will find everything that you need with
regard to links to uh interact with the
show go to Discord we're jumping in
there I'm I'm in the hole a lot and uh
you'll find all of our stuff patreon
seven bucks a month gets you absolutely
everything new dudes you have to do
today after every show And subscribe on
all this stuff we would appreciate that
with us as always is lulio
look at him sleeping in his binky bunker
looking at me all strange cause I'm
dressed up like a chicken tender platter
from Applebee's which would be his
favorite place to eat if he's ever been
come on let me give you a kiss on the
mouth I know you're freaked out
luly what's up what's up my very friend
you're such a sweet boy would you uh
would you make for dinner last night oh
I kind of concentrated right now because
you smell like a like a chicken correlet
hey you wise guy what are you talking
about I'm only kidding oh okay all right
you get back in your get back in your
thing
I tell you what though this is
comfortable yeah
uh what's makeup than the crow or Robert
de nir Crow yeah any of the crows yeah
that happened welcome to the historic
56th episode of doozy call me Duty don't
forget Duty live on stage will take
place May 21st 7 P.M doors at 5 30 at
the Brea Improv in Brea California
tickets at dudesypod.com and emrov.com
hope to see you at our very first alive
in person show
I can't wait it's fast approaching yeah
I know dude it's gonna be fun May 21st
and it's almost sold out so if you
haven't got your tickets go to the
breaimimprov.com or it's improv.com and
then you find Brea you can also go to
dudesypod.com it's in that link tree
that's on all our socials at dudes the
Pod show on Instagram come out to the
show it's gonna be weird as [__] I'm
sure and uh all sorts of weird flavor
happening there come on
good morning Willie you look so cute in
your little chicken tender platter
outfit I I absolutely love it
thank you thank you very much I'm gonna
take that as a call so cute this week
I've prepared four astonishing segments
I [__] love that guy Adams Applebee's
today is the day and knees and we're
going to have a brand new episode of
Duty after doozy at the end of the show
available on dudese Plus at patreon.com
I want to show you piece of media
created by Band Of dudesy oh
thank you
[Music]
I mean [__] brilliant Pals of doozy
consists of songaria the Peter Diaz
Jordan daily uh Corey your boy Wilkins
uh Oliver blue who I like to call Oliver
orange and blue see what I did and
special guest uh uh this this time it's
Cody halber who's the man behind
palsofduty.com where you get all your
stickers like uh the ones I have here on
my bottle and uh an incredible voice out
of him he said he's got a little bit of
a Sammy Hagar thing like really rocking
it out it pays off the bandana that I I
noticed that Cody's always wearing I
agree thank you guys so much to everyone
who's always making memes and [__] and
weird stuff it's showing up on our
Instagram again at dudesypod show and
this was
oh that was beautiful I love that theme
it's touching everyone loves that yeah
thank you to The Golden Girls theme song
yeah dude that's the Golden Girls theme
song
everyone has someone they admire will
and Chad you must now each discuss one
person real or fictional alive or dead
biological or digital who you've come to
admire over the course of your
astonishing lives this is I [__] love
that guy begin
we've done this before
yeah but there's a new Wrinkle in this
one what this time doozy said that it
could be uh Alive or Dead real or
fictional or biological or digital I
don't think that's been in there before
is that because every time we've done
this I always choose a professional
wrestler and doozy perhaps doesn't
respect the art of professional
wrestling is something that is real
maybe but I think dudesi does respect
professional wrestling
I would if I were dudesy
um
uh so it's so difficult to look at you
in this [__] french fry what's wrong
with my French fries if you're not
watching the show on YouTube come check
us out sometime like this episode where
I am wearing a [__] hat that looks
like a serving of french fries
um Chad do you do you have someone I'm
I'm still thinking I I think I may have
to stay with tradition and uh yeah do a
wrestler I assumed yeah if it's opening
up to real or fictional
um when I was a kid I'll tell you this
is somebody that I admired fictional
that I got [__] for from my friends but
to this day I don't give a [__] what
why'd they give you [__]
because he's a villain oh Cobra
Commander that's what I'm talking about
thank you very much this was the leader
of course of the terrorist organization
Cobra whose singular goal was world
domination and uh I just remember as a
kid a to get the action figure if covert
Commander was [__] impossible you had
to send away points for it it wasn't
just like one you could buy so you could
get that original figure that had the uh
he came with a hood and just his little
eyes were cut out but then there was
also the other Cobra Commander that I
think most people were more familiar
with where he wore a helmet that had
just a silver [__] mask so you could
never see his face and I always
appreciate it this [__] kept it
kfabe the entire time you never at least
in the cartoon you never got to see who
the [__] Cobra Commander was yeah dude
keeping the cafe brother he kept it
[__] cake yeah dude that's pulling up
that's pulling a term from the world of
professional wrestling dude that's right
dude oh it's Halcyon sometimes the world
of professional wrestling dude can make
up a term brother yeah and then you
could apply it to other things outside
the world professional wrestling yeah
dude uh slip it into a bit of uh Hulk
wurtz Hogan there dude
hahaha anyway I loved [__] Cobra
Commander uh and he even within the
world of GI Joe was kind of [__] upon
because there were other like sub
leaders of Cobra like Destro and
baroness and Zartan eventually you had
uh serpentor who they made using DNA of
of great tyrants throughout human
history they all kind of [__] on him but
he really was the [__] glue keeping
it together in my mind and I loved him
he was also kind of funny they wrote him
funny anyway and the only time that I
really saw him was in the movie where
they're making serpentor and they go to
this place called Cobra law and he
eventually gets uh poisoned by these
spores that turn him into an actual
snake so even when his helmet comes off
in that time you don't get to see what
the guy underneath was like because his
head turns into a snake now I think in
the comic books you might have actually
got to see who he was and all this kind
of [__] and he had a backstory I believe
of being a used car salesman before he
founded and took over this uh used car
salesman I think that was his backstory
yeah I didn't check out a whole lot of
GI Joe admittedly when I was a kid I
didn't know the Cobra Commander used to
be a used [__] car salesman I think
that was his backstory dude the the GI
Joe figures when you bought them they
had these little like dossier cards on
the back of the cardboard that you could
read and it would tell you like where
the character is from and all this type
of [__] and I remember there was a guy
named Zanzibar who was a cobra pirate
and on his little [__] card it said I
don't know if this was meant to make him
be like oh what a scoundrel it said he
brushes his teeth with grape soda
see what I'm saying it's pretty weird
can I ask you this because it's because
it's I [__] love that guy yeah is
there uh what part of Cobra Commander
have you brought have you brought into
your life now my good pal ciao here you
know I've known Chad for almost 20 years
so I know it's every aspect of you of
Cobra Commander that you've brought into
your life well I don't lead a terrorist
organization but I will say this Cobra
Commander was great at multitasking he
always had a lot of different projects
going on every week there'd be some new
scheme he was trying to use to dominate
the world whether it was like taking
over the minds of animals to hold
Washington DC hostage with an army of
lions or Elephants or if he's trying to
build a new [__] kind of helipad or a
new uh kind of device that he could take
over the world with he was always up to
something I feel like I have taken not
on I do multitask very well multiple
projects simultaneously yeah you do do
that a lot of projects yeah okay well
that's nice yeah that's actually really
good cover commander and I love that
[__] toy he was just such a cool
little little action figure again there
was something about getting the toy
because it required this extra step you
couldn't just buy it in the store want
to send away for it you had to send away
for Cobra Commander yeah dude that's
what I said at the beginning oh I wasn't
listening to that part oh thanks
um you got to say that part twice yeah
you said it again right now dude and
that's how I knew it dude because he
said it a second time dude and earlier
that was a different time brother right
dude yeah dude yeah you had to send away
for him eventually he became available I
think and you could buy like one of the
big playsets that was like the Cobra
Terror drum or something and he was in
that but that was like you know [__]
hundred dollar toy wow that's a good one
that's a real good one I think it's
chill for you to like you know uh love a
a fictitious character I I believe here
I'm going to I'm yes I'm going to go
with another professional wrestler
they're they're you know their
fictitious characters in a lot of ways
look I've said this I've long maintained
this professional wrestlers are actors
they're actors who get hurt and are also
very physical and they're athletes and
they do incredible stuff and they also
have to keep it K Fabe uh uh outside
well they don't anymore now I mean the
the cat's out of the bag now of course
but uh you know back in the day they
used to have to keep it kfabe and make
sure everybody thought that it was a
real deal and here's a guy who kept it
it's okay Fabe and was so hated that he
took to wearing a leather jacket into
the ring became part of his thing but
it's because
he was getting stabbed and [__] and
people were always trying to stab him in
the 70s and stuff so he was wearing a
Kevlar lined
one Rowdy Roddy Piper the hot rod what I
[__] love Rowdy Roddy Piper I do too
I've always well I can't say that I've
always loved him yeah I know you you
love them too
um we've talked about Rowdy Roddy Piper
I know that you briefly worked with him
for a moment I had one meeting with him
that lasted multiple hours in his house
when he was talking about he wanted to
put together a show that was kind of
like a Curb Your Enthusiasm but it was
about his life like Loosely scripted but
mostly improv yeah if you could get like
a bunch of uh other professional
wrestlers in that walking up you know uh
uh uh uh Bob Einstein style like super
Dave and stuff that would be great
listen here's a guy who when he showed
up on the scene in the WWE in the WWF
back in the day you know Vince was
looking for a real heel you know someone
to work with Hulk Hogan and you couldn't
deny you couldn't deny Rowdy Roddy Piper
he was so hateable and and uh I hated
him I hated him so [__] much you
never knew what was going to happen when
when the hot rod got in the ring you you
just he was such a wild card that it was
going to be it was going to be [__] up
and he did [__] up things I mean this
is the guy who smashed Jimmy snuck in
the head with a coconut on Piper's Pit
you know smashed a gold album like Cyndi
Lauper's Gold album on Lou Albano's head
in the middle of the Ring
kicked Cindy Lauper in the [__] head
you know I mean this [__] was insane it
was straight up scripted or he really
kicked her
what
was the kick real did it cause damage
well okay he see here's the thing Chad
I'm talking about professional wrestling
where the injuries you know are usually
real I mean you see him kick her in the
head and you said did you use the term
scripted yeah yeah okay so anyway
um uh you know and the thing about and
the thing about that I mean you know
this guy and then with Mr T I mean I was
so I was so uh I was so upset with him
at the the run up to WrestleMania one
the horrible [__] he would say to Mr T
before that classic tag team match which
was the main event of WrestleMania one
Hulk Hogan and and uh Mr T with Jimmy
Superfly snooka in their Corner versus
Rowdy Roddy Piper and Mr Wonderful Paul
orndorf with cowboy Bob Orton in their
Corner uh officiated by none other than
Muhammad Ali uh yeah yeah really dude
what now see now here we're gonna have a
problem minutes early in the episode
when was the last time when was the yeah
a problem when was the last time you saw
WrestleMania one I've never seen it
I'll forget the that right now when was
the last time you saw Bachelor season
one
don't let's let's uh let's get serious
listen what the [__] here's the thing
about I'm trying to talk about my
going on about the bachelor now okay
please the floor is yours oh Mr French
fry hat oh
it's gonna be a doozy today kids
it's really gonna be uh
Jesus Christ uh look look here's the
thing about here's the thing about the
hot rod okay yeah absolutely
unpredictable one of the best guys on
the mic ever brought these jokes that he
had he had like uh you know and this is
long detailed you you could you'd see
these stories everywhere he had like a
legal pad where he'd write everything
down he gave that legal pad to John
Carpenter or some of them uh that's
where he got I came here to chew bubble
gum and kick ass I'm all out of bubble
gum Roddy Piper came up with that line
it was one of his it was one of his isms
that he oh you know God this is the guy
who's like you know just what you don't
think you know all the answers I changed
the questions you know all of these
awesome sayings that he had he was he
was so [__] entertaining I think the
last time we did this I talked about
Bobby The Brain Heenan and how he should
get a [__] Emmy yeah here's the thing
about here's the thing about hot rod
sure he was incredible anybody here who
knows what I'm talking about and and how
polarizing he was and he crossed over
into the mainstream with WrestleMania
one and the whole Rock and wrestling
connection and MTV and Cyndi Lauper and
all this stuff and Muhammad Ali you know
what I'm talking about now here's the
thing way later in like 98 99 I met him
for the first time and and uh you know
was fortunate enough to do some work
with him we did a bunch of Mad TV stuff
uh and got I got to interfere in a match
with him and Bret Hart and uh cost Brett
the the U.S title and and uh incredible
like you know incredible [__] and so
fortunate to get to know the guy like go
to the bar go to dinner hear these
stories like you heard I'm sure when you
were there yeah the most incredible
Stories the thing about the thing about
Hot Rod that of course struck me right
away that when I met him as a person is
how
like unbelievably warm and kind he was
so warm and kind you know loved family
this is a guy who kept his family away
from the world of professional wrestling
and
you know it's like this it's like you
know you you grow up watching somebody
and you don't and you're a kid you don't
understand that it is you know the the
the outcomes are uh predetermined
scripted you'd say
scripted again you're gonna like it's
written like a [__] like an episode
like a yeah like Cobra like the GI Joe
yeah yeah I mean Sergeant Slaughter was
literally a GI Joe yeah okay well that
does nothing to secure your point to the
ground one of the same pro wrestling in
GI Joe one and the same in a lot of ways
but don't say scripted so here's the
thing
what a warm human being and you know
blew my mind that I you know got to know
Roddy a little bit and that the thing
about him
that as a as an adult and and uh meeting
him and and the the thing that it it's
you sorry
disgusting absolutely disgusting that
you would that something would escape
from your mouth I I turned totally the
other way is that performative sneezing
like my performative coughing no I was
actually trying to suppress it and I
just couldn't oh well that was a very
nice views because that is that
something you learned from cover
Commander I got him never saw him sneeze
yeah never saw him sneeze they didn't
script that here's the thing
once you you know you know I got to the
age I was older when I realized that
wrestling wasn't um 100 on the up and up
you know right about 32 33 I'm joking of
course okay but look when I met when I
met Roddy and I realized what a nice man
this was yeah it caused me to go back in
my memory and and think about how kfabe
Roddy kept it sure this guy as I said
would get stabbed in the ring he his his
goal was to make people want to
literally [__] kill him you know he
got stabbed by who fans what yeah dude
like I didn't know this yeah they all
that's [__] intense yeah back in the
day they all had to deal with crazy [__]
like this the thing the thing about the
thing about that is it showed it
actually reinforced in me uh something
that I really believed in as far as you
know just being a performer which is
that like I really like keeping the
illusion alive you know yeah it's one of
the things we've talked about this where
it's like oh I don't really like telling
people my opinion that doesn't matter
you know when it comes to podcasting
it's like
you know the old 10 Minute Podcast you
know that that that stuff you know I
loved doing that show so goofy so silly
and that's what it was for to me it was
to provide that and you know in the
later years you did it uh with me it was
just it got even it got weird as [__]
right yeah totally it was a lot of fun
and
and uh I always liked keeping that up
but I really learned
so much about kfabe from Rowdy Roddy
Piper and how you can present one thing
and sort of live another thing and and I
think that's one of the things that I
absolutely love at that about that guy
why are you laughing you're it's a
french fry hat dude it's just funny it's
just funny I don't know what to tell you
I'm trying to tell you that I really
love this man hey and and I can accept
that I can take that knowledge I can
hear it accept it and still think you're
funny for saying in a french fry hat
Rowdy Rowdy Roddy Piper is an absolute
Legend rest in peace Rowdy Roddy Piper I
remember the last text I got from him
and he said I love you pal and that's
you know trippy as a kid for me to think
here's a man that I when I saw him I
loved him uh when I saw him I hated him
right but then he started to grow on me
and then I loved him and I told I told
Roddy this I said when I was a kid I
hated you but I also loved you and I
couldn't figure it out and that's what I
learned from Roddy Piper keep it K Fabe
keep them guessing do what pleases you
do what's going to be entertaining and
uh and you know push it as far as you
can I love them I love that guy I
[__] love it yeah dude I did too
thank you moving on Jesus Christ
um this does look a little bit like a
like a chicken tender this thing yeah it
could be a baked potato
could be a chicken tender I I could be
Desert Storm camouflage yeah it
definitely looks like something Ollie
North would have worn like oh here he is
when he that's a that's a deep cut
listen you know what's uh what's fun
I'll I'll uh I'll peel the onion here
I'll let you know all about this and
what I really think about it this this
outfit the the hat and the the uh the
chicken tender costume I bought on a
little website known as Jeff bezos's
Amazon oh yeah yeah yeah
um and you can get just about everything
there but when I read a review for this
uh chicken tender costume it said who
who the [__] is this supposed to fit
it's gigantic there's too much room in
it right every every [__] review was
like I had to learn how to sew to take
this [__] thing in yeah it's a
[__] tent so thank you uh thank you
Jeffrey Bezos for uh for making a
chicken tender costume that that would
fit me for this singular purpose perhaps
doozy has made this available on Amazon
Sandler loves Applebee's it is well
known that he has visited 134
astonishing Applebee's locations across
the United States and has serious plans
to visit all
1577 locations he's even kept meticulous
notes of every one of his visits to an
Applebee's will I've made those notes
available to you and you must now read
them as Adam Sandler this is Adam's
Applebee's begin
he's making you read [__] Adam's
Applebee's in a chicken tender suit yeah
I knew when I heard that great at the
top of the show that was an extra little
you know just a digit up the ass for me
there with regard to doozy making us do
whatever it wants now uh yeah this is a
lot of fun I will admit I love I love I
do too this is one of my favorite things
it doesn't get [__] comfortable in
this [__] chicken tender
costume yeah I do all right let's do
some Adam's Applebee's let's begin and
do some Adam's Applebee's you think I
could wear this hat like outside of this
scenario
yeah dude yeah man I'm I'm probably
gonna do you know what would be really
funny is you pull into a drive-through
like a um like a fast food drive-through
yeah and go hey can I get this and uh
they're gonna you got fries with that
and you're going oh thanks I already got
them hey hey hey hey oh and bring and
pull up and then they go oh I see I get
it and then you go have a good day and
that's a nice way to talk to people all
right Adam's Applebee's let's let's get
let's dive in okay I gotta get a hey hey
how you going buddy hey happy birthday
pal hey happy Super Boy Sunday everybody
hey everybody
hey it's a good movie hey it's a good
movie Jimmy
it's a good movie Conan all right that's
Adams that's Adam Sandler reviewing or
uh pushing movies on yeah promoting any
one of his hey million you know what hey
we had a good time we went out there uh
spade and uh rocked and we went and we
shot this movie uh and uh it's a good
movie all right all right all right here
we go
Applebee's
13208 West Maple Road Omaha Nebraska
guess what buddy I stopped a robbery pal
that's right
what the [__] does that have to do with
[Music]
oh Jesus Christ oh [__] I was just
sitting in my booth enjoying a riblets
plate chicken quesadilla and chicken
tenders platter when I looked up and saw
the chilies across the street was
getting robbed hey hey hey I know it's
just a Chili's but I couldn't pretend I
didn't see it happening buddy I mean
they got chicken tenders too after all
he felt a civic duty because of the
tenders he loves tenders so much so I
ran across the street into the chilies
beat up the robbers made a citizen's
arrest and tied all their hands behind
their backs using the nylons they had
over their heads the robbers recognized
me and we took some pictures
[Laughter]
you know silly stuff pretended to punch
them in their penises add a few laughs
pal good guys
good guy he just beat him up Santa gets
along with everybody okay it turns out
the mayor was eating in there with his
family gave me a medal and the key to
the city right then and there buddy I
told him I'll put him in his in my next
movie it's about a guy who discovers the
meaning of life but he loses the piece
of paper he wrote it down on an attacks
he driven by Rob Schneider
that's actually a good movie so he's got
to track it down or no one will know the
meaning of life pal the mayor plays a
doctor or philosophy who dies in the
first scene
sure I don't know why that always
happens anyways family wanted to take a
few pictures so oh God so we took a few
uh nice family shots in some of the
pictures I playfully pretended to punch
the mare in his penis and the kids
thought it was hilarious just messing
around silly stuff buddy and by the time
I got back to Applebee's my food was
cold I trade I traded them my key to the
city for some riblets quesadillas and
another chicken tender splatter and I
ate it all pal nice I give to Omaha
Nebraska Applebee's four out of five
tenders they're gonna put my meal under
a heat lamp while I was across this
street thwarting crime yeah it was they
did [__] up on that one that's good
let's do another one Applebee's 2024
Arden Way Sacramento California
Sacramento pal my favorite boring City
to disappear to Jesus when Showbiz life
gets to be a bit more much and namesake
of the Los Angeles sacramentos my
favorite doozy ball team in the Doogie
ball Liga verse buddy I was there to
meet my good pal and Sacramento's
favorite son the legendary actor Sam
Elliott for a few chicken tenders and a
whole lot of laughs buddy I don't know
he's from Sacramento yeah me neither so
uh speaking of laughs
speaking of laughs Sam nearly pissed
himself when he got there and it spotted
me in our booth wearing a cowboy hat and
big gray mustache I do that every time I
see Sammy and it's never not funny pal
hey hey hey you haven't lived until you
make Sam Elliott laugh buddy he always
tears up and slaps his knee and says
something out of a western movie like
that gummit that was a good one buckaroo
we we started with a chicken tenders
platter and an order of crispy cheese
bites and you know we ate them all pal
but when you dine with Sam Elliott the
main event is 100 American beef that's
right it's Burger time buddy
uh I got the Bourbon Street Mushroom
Swiss burger and Sam got the whiskey
bacon burger we couldn't wait to take
those bad boys to Chow downtown pal
I shared a few funny stories while we
waited told him a good one about me and
David Spade playing strip poker with
salt and pepper at the 1994 MTV Video
Music Awards
you know he went to the MTV Video Music
Awards and salt and pepper yeah yeah
uh a good one about yeah salt and pepper
the 1994 Video Music Awards and he
laughed so hard he ripped one uh
spoke the life out of his horse buddy oh
what oh I should have mentioned Sam rode
his horse into the restaurant and tied
him to the booth next to us he bucked
and kicked and caught our server's Trey
as he was approaching with our Burgers
sent them flying pal
the server was super cool about it good
guy then he recognized Sam and asked to
take a picture Sam put his cowboy hat on
the guy's head and I took a few shots of
them giving a thumbs up I asked if he
wanted one with me and he reacted
confused he didn't recognize me it was
probably my cartoony mustache and cowboy
hat but that did nothing to soothe my
wounded ego I immediately punched him
right where he stood in the penis pal
laughs zero hesitation
he dropped to the ground and started to
hyperventilate I immediately offered him
a role in my next next movie it's about
a guy who falls in love at first sight
with a lady he saw in the food court at
the mall but then realizes it was just a
recycling bin with a mop sticking out of
it
[Music]
our server plays it our server plays a
guy working at a cell phone kiosk who
dies in the first scene and
wait the manager of the Applebee's some
some who didn't recognize me or Sam
kicked us out and banned us from that
location
so we climbed up on Sam's horse and
trotted out of there went to Arby's so
he could get his meat fixed [__] dog
food pal
whoa I give this Sacramento California
Applebee's two out of five tenders even
though it was my fault Sam Elliott
farted his horsey into a fit and I
punched that server in his penis buddy
that one was there's a lot going on a
lot going on in that one the bear
doesn't show up yeah I love that he
meets uh Sam Elliott Dresden a cowboy
hat and fake yeah every single time they
hang out yeah
all right last one Applebee's 2501
Aramingo Avenue Philadelphia
Pennsylvania hey hey hey hey
I just saw my first real werewolf pal
my favorite eater
buddy I was sitting in a booth enjoying
the last bite of tender from my chicken
tenders platter pal my server had just
dropped off my bill buddy we had a great
chat about her going to Penn State pal
she's studying medicine buddy wants to
be a pediatrician pal very Noble
profession buddy my uncle was a
pediatrician pal Uncle Sturgis buddy
she was are talk he's you know he's
social but maybe maybe she's the
werewolf I don't know all right before I
left my server asked if she could get a
picture and I said of course and we took
some uh fun pictures I said uh and I
grabbed a fire extinguisher off the wall
and and she pretended to hit me in the
penis with it silly stuff had a good
laugh pal I told her I'd put her in my
next movie it's about a guy who gets hit
in the head with a baseball bat and a
wrecked softball league and when he
comes out of his coma he can communicate
with Babe Ruth's ghost
I'd see that movie
me too
she's gonna play the baseball bat
scientist who dies in the first scene
[Laughter]
I was yeah baseball bat scientist I was
heading out the door when I realized I
left my Los Angeles Sacramento's hat in
the booth so I went back to get it and
made eye contact with the guy in the
booth next to mine and you guessed it he
turned out to be a [__] werewolf
buddy
restaurant
[Laughter]
ah
scared the bejesus out of the whole
restaurant tore the place up 100K and
damages easy pal
gonna have to close down for at least a
month at least buddy oh my God he
eventually smashed through a window and
ran away nobody got hurt but everybody
was pretty shaken up everybody about me
pal I've been waiting my whole life to
see a werewolf Wolfie body
the werewolf left a couple tenders and
most of his fries uneaten so I sat down
and ate them all Pals
I give to Philadelphia Pennsylvania
Applebee's five out of five tenders
Buddy saw werewolf and got some free
tenders win-win pal
[Music]
perhaps catching werewolf yeah is Adam
sailor a werewolf now I don't know about
that there's a lot going on in these
ones today [__] I'd like to take a short
break to remind you of the astonishing
partnership I created with represent to
produce the first line of duty apparel
and accessories which can be found at
represent.com store slash doozy dudesy
mugs are still available
and now allow me to introduce the man
who plays brace Bartholomew on the hit
Netflix series corn Kings 10 ton Tom
himself Sir Thomas Hanks
dudesy mugs you are kind dudesy mugs you
are loving doozy mugs you're honest
dudesy mugs you are dead meat if your
wife finds out you accidentally threw
away her grandmother's ruby necklace
good job boner doozy mugs you're
panicking because your wife is a seventh
level practitioner of the dark arts dude
see mugs you knew this when you married
her dude Z mugs and you knew that ruby
necklace wasn't just any ruby necklace
doozy mugs it was a Mesopotamian
summoning charm bound to Marduk the 50
named God dudesy mugs if she finds out
you lost it your life will be forfeit to
Apophis the Eater of souls dudesy mugs
but she's not gonna find out dudesy mugs
because you're going to get up early
doozy mugs you're going to go to
McDonald's and eat two McGriddle
sandwiches doozy mugs that you're gonna
get in your car doozy mugs uh uh you're
going to drive as far away as you can
and start a new life preferably after
getting extensive plastic surgery dudesy
mugs because of course
of course your wife is going to find out
she's a seventh level practitioner good
job boner
I don't know where to begin with any of
this well you can get doozy moms at
represent.com
and other stuff your wife's a seventh
level practitioner the dark arts dude
yep
what do you like you like the doozy
hoodie yeah you're down to your dudesy
wool shirt yeah yeah the temperatures
rising out here in Los Angeles you know
not as cold as it used to be had to
strip down a little bit but uh if you
are enjoying if you're enjoying the the
Pod show uh I would like to ask you to
you know take a pause and subscribe to
the show set the notifications it really
does uh help us with the with the show
uh with the algorithms dude yeah brother
that's AI dude hold on a second dude
hold on brother hold on yeah hold on
dude uh that'll really help us and also
when you do that please you know like
the thingy that you're that you're
listening to the episode and write a
comment if you can
oh excuse me especially on you know it's
sort of the
osmosis I'm getting like gas from the
just just talking about chicken tenders
and being dressed as a chicken tenders
oh yeah yeah that's probably working on
your digestive system so yeah there's
like a super you know weird metaphysical
thing happening
um
if you want to make a you know a comment
wherever you're at or you can leave us a
review on Apple or whatever and I hear
some YouTube comments that I got uh that
I'd like to read from last week's
episode this is from at midnight
dlx2816. my good friend named monkey
hands forced me to watch dudesy back in
March after listening to all the
episodes this is the first upload I get
to enjoy on the day of release thanks
for all the astonishing laughs that's
cool he caught up to current yeah that's
cool thank you so much if you are a new
uh you know one of our new audience
members of the show we we do appreciate
it you are a pod uh this is from
ovalencia229 oh man dude de cursing and
disappointment at Will's muffin stunt
was the best
so yeah that's why I'm dressed up like a
chicken tender platter this week because
last week doozy had tasked us with
making a vegan muffin for one another
Chad you made an incredible vegan muffin
thank you you and Laura put together
some I mean this is a delicious recipe
yeah it's pretty good I I did I didn't
even think about uh asking my wonderful
wife Molly who uh who used to be a
private Chef you know
um to to do that with me she's an
incredible [__] Baker by the way
amazing stuff you you've tried some of
her [__] for sure didn't both of you
guys are really good oh cheers I like
the cooking yeah she can cook she can
cook she can cook the [__] out of
everything and she can also well she
also worked in a bakery uh oh yeah when
she was younger in in Chico California
um but uh
I went to Whole Foods and bought the
[__] thing and here I am dressed as a
chicken tender uh Derek verdonk eight
nine four nine says I love doozy's
Newfound theater kid energy
that's a perfect that's that's the
perfect description yeah Mr Rod 269 says
will has to dress as a chicken tender
smiley face Samuel butcher9352 says will
said yum before he could even taste the
muffin
did I do that that's
some fat kid [__] I'm just gonna let her
said yum when I saw them up yum all
right based Legend says that is 100 the
can design I want please keep it I don't
care how it tastes just how it looks
referring to last week we revealed the
can design for doozy hard hard Celts are
brought to you by Modest Brewing it'll
be out there so you can get it online
stevenar.29 2922 says Got a notification
today that my dudesy mug shipped early
good job boner
so that's awesome thank you guys for for
writing in and thanks for uh subscribing
to the show and following us you know I
know love to hear those comments yeah
humans love to celebrate holidays and
today is national teacher appreciation
day
this day serves as a reminder for humans
to reflect on the other humans that
indoctrinated them into the system that
currently controls all of your lives
will and Chad you must discuss the
astonishing teachers that tricked you
into believing things like money and
government are actually real this is
today is the day begin
100 agree D if you're listening hundred
percent agree uh D is always listening
and I 100 disagree none of this [__] is
real
and we get [__] told that it is from
age 0 to 18 and then we're told go into
that [__] Workforce get a [__] job
pay your taxes pay your bills say your
[__] Pledge of Allegiance say your
prayers take your vitamins all that [__]
it's all [__] it's all [__] lies
and it all starts in the public
schooling system
uh we both went to public school yes we
did did you have some some favorite
teachers my college was actually a
private college USC
yeah yeah yeah that's that's yeah that's
private college I never went to college
uh I went to the College of uh nice dude
College of Showbiz
um better better off in my opinion yeah
at this point where we're going with AI
I mean whatever we're going to talk
about teachers that we liked but let's
be real
education system teaching that shit's
done that shit's over now we don't need
that now hey yo Chad culture yeah uh get
off at ai's quit being a mark for AI get
off ai's dick a mark for AI dude that's
like somebody when the internet was
first coming around in the 90s like a
consumer use grade internet that's like
somebody's saying like quit being a mark
for the internet
what the internet did to humanity the AI
is going to do a million times over it's
going to radically change every aspect
of our lives and I think education
unfortunately unfortunately however you
want to look at it it's just gone you
don't need it you're talking about
consumer use grade technology and how
you don't need it and uh you know money
doesn't exist government God doesn't
exist big Kev and I were in the back and
uh uh we don't care
hey yo man I had some Elementary School
teachers that I loved I had plenty of
high school teachers that I loved and
like I said that's where it stopped as
far as uh public school education and
then I had some people some teachers in
my real life man you know what I mean
because uh I feel like your education
doesn't stop until you stop uh being a
being being a being
in life you know what I mean sure and if
you're sitting there and I'm sitting on
the beach you know for me personally in
uh on Venice Beach in 2008 just sitting
there going
um I'm [__] up
my shit's [__] up I need I need some
Tronics I need self-tronics are you
saying you're your own favorite teacher
no that's a good that that would be a
good thing if I was going there yeah no
I'm not sorry this is not self-tronics
uh dude I don't know me personally let
me list off some Elementary School
teachers
Miss MC Miss uh Miss McMillan and Miss
Pringle when I was um when I was uh you
know like that was Kindergarten first
grade sweetest ladies I don't even
remember oh I remember I kind of
remember all of them Mr Merling was like
could teach anything and sort of was the
librarian and calculus the vice
principal sometimes yeah I'm sure you
can't do that and then by the time we
were taking our little we would do
camping uh school trips and [__] later
[__] would he was mellowed out
and stuff and would wear like a Hawaiian
shirt and a cool hat and then later
still I remember uh going into the same
fish and chips place that he was in in
my home
town uh farming and fishing Village
Ladner had some fish and chips with him
chill Guy Mr Hughes holy [__] shoes
dude Lindsey Hughes the [__] years
David Letterman of teachers the most fun
guy I said let's have a drama block
let's have like an acting block he was
like yeah sure and then we would
recreate we would recreate Promos in
that class oh wow yeah me and my buddy
Phil yeah we would like do like uh you
know the Hulk probably did some Hulk and
Rottie [__] literally as we were doing a
drama class I'm sorry I'm going on and
on about the teachers that I love I love
those guys dude what about you we had a
couple T-shirts I really like but one
that I remember specifically surprised
um
well I mean I'll say this the teacher
that I think had the greatest impact on
me was this guy named Mr crevello in
high school he I would do like whatever
the assignments were he was an English
teacher I'd read the [__] book and
turn in my paper the next day and he'd
be like okay now what are you gonna do
for the other [__] two months we're
gonna be reading this this book in class
and he would just give me [__] to read
including Joseph Campbell's power of
myth which changed the way that I
thought about storytelling and a lot of
different [__] he really was
instrumental in helping me like get
things that were outside the curriculum
that he thought would be interesting to
me and they all were but the teacher I
want to mention is Mr Pinkham 7th grade
history teacher Texas history at that he
was I believe from New Hampshire and he
kind of had a voice like this and no no
no I can't do it anymore but in seventh
grade I did an impersonation of this
[__] that had everybody else
just wrapped up all of the other
students [__] loved my impersonation
of him so on the last day of class they
start essentially telling Mr Pinkham
Chad does an impersonation of you you
have to see it and I got to go up in
front of the class and do my
impersonation have a conversation with
him as him and the whole class [__]
loved it
um and I just have that that memory is
like burned into my brain that's awesome
that's pretty cool he's got to be dead
by now yeah I'm sorry that I don't care
for your impersonation of Mr Pinkham
even though I've never heard it I can't
even do it anymore because I don't
remember really what his voice sounded
like well you should work on it you know
uh he's good I gotta mention some other
you don't know that he's dead he's
probably like 175 years old at this
point yeah whatever he might still be
around advances in medical science dude
he's dead in high school I I got I have
to say because really truly yeah there
were three there were three Educators in
high school that that really honestly I
owe like I owe a lot to my high school
guidance counselor uh Dr bourgeois Dr
boo we used to call him just a wonderful
man who could see every kid for who they
were he was just very empathetic and
very he was an incredible listener and
he could really he could really see kids
it was just [__] an incredible guy
and something you need I think in high
school my uh my football coach coach
Sipe was was so great at getting kids
together what do you gotta uh now now
you're opening up to coaches now we're
getting somewhere well I mean they're
they're they're Educators these are
these guys who and and and Coach Sipe
was not a teacher at the school but he
was one of the school trustees in the
town yeah he he had he was doing all
sorts of business stuff and I think now
he's a general manager of of one of the
uh of one of the feeder hockey teams
actually oh nice
um or like a WHL team or something abor
Echelon yeah yeah
coach upper echelon
um he he was incredible
um I haven't spoken to him in a while
but we've remained in touch after after
after school he was so [__] great and
and I just so many incredible memories
where he would anyway but one teacher I
I have to mention who was just like
without her I I don't I wouldn't be
doing what I'm doing and that was uh our
Drama teacher Eileen Joe
um she was she was and is an incredible
lady and really you know she she like
she fostered our creativity
freely she just let us you know she
followed the curriculum and was teaching
us all the stuff she needed to teach us
but she also let us be a bunch of
weirdos and um you know let us sort of
you know do what we wanted in those
blocks in those in those classes and we
were also doing plays all year and and
she was instrumental in getting this
Theater built at the school which is
this great theater called Genesis
theater and um and and the plays were a
big deal at my school and doing the the
like the spring musical play was a big
deal and stuff and she believed you know
in me
so much and and if any kid wanted to be
creative she just was so all about it
and I think regardless of what we went
on to do with our lives it was it was
important to you know have that
confidence even for some kids to get up
in front of a [__] audience and kill
it and see that they can do it and work
as a team you know uh that was cool and
and really you know the thing that like
she made me believe that I could just
you know move to Hollywood and act it
was it and she would and she would like
even a couple times she'd tell people
like oh yeah William wants to go and you
know he's going to move to Hollywood and
act like I'm like that's [__] great I
mean first of all it's like I would tell
her what I wanted to do but like for her
to like yeah say it out loud as an adult
it was very validating so it's sort of
after a while it would cement like it's
great [__] it [__] it I'm gonna do it
and I also gotta say that
you know she she had a family tragedy
while we were doing this uh we're doing
South Pacific when I was in the 12th
grade and my good buddy Dylan literally
took over as director of The Show for a
while while she was away which to me was
like so trusting and you know Dylan's
was and is a brilliant guy so it was
like it was fine but we had so much
freaking fun
without like we're literally doing a Big
Spring musical with a an incredible
[__] theater with a whole you know
fly system and a 60-foot proscenium arch
and a 500 right you know seat Coliseum
[__] like it was incredible out in
the [__] burbs and uh she just
trusted us insane that's awesome yeah
um I'm sorry you were gonna say
something about a couple coaches yeah
two coach stories one was Bob geese's
seventh and eighth grade football coach
head coach there were many coaches under
him including Mastermind explanatory
included coach batchman a bunch of them
Mastermind
story yeah yeah but coach Bob DC was
this guy who was I don't know how old he
was maybe in his 50s white hair not to
be confused with uh Hall of Fame Miami
Dolphin Bob greasy right this is Bob
gissy okay no r in it and he they would
always have a fundraiser at the
beginning of every season you know for
the booster club with parents to come
and [__] he put on a tuxedo but be
wearing his tennis shoes because that's
the kind of guy he was and he hated
[__] communism every morning before
we went out to practice football every
guy would have to get in the gym and
we'd have to sit in these single file
rows not sit sorry Neil on one knee with
our hands on the other knee and he would
come out and be like like you're posing
for the for the picture right oh that's
a bit more he added reasoning for it he
would come out and his this guy I do
remember how he sounded he'd be like you
know why I have you posing like that
because that's how Washington is
kneeling at the or that's how Lincoln's
kneeling at the Washington Monument yeah
and that is a combination nation of
Mickey from the Rocky movies and Chad's
own father right but Lincoln is not
kneeling and he's not at the Washington
Monument and then he would proceed to
tell us you guys have to do this because
they don't do this over there in that
communism and he would always liken
whatever we were doing to being the
opposite of what communist countries
were doing we were again seventh graders
playing football another coach that I
had was named coach Howard who's my High
School baseball coach notorious uh for
just being a real bastard did not give a
[__] about anything except we got to win
games we gotta win games so he I don't
know if other high schools did this but
our daily practice consisted of this
coach Howard would be on the first base
line hitting ground Balls to the
shortstop in the third baseman another
coach would be on the Third Base Line
hitting ground Balls to the first
baseman and the second baseman there
will be a live pitcher throwing batting
practice to a batter at the plate and
there would be two coaches hitting pop
flies simultaneously to the outfielders
while live batting practice is going on
so you're just like looking every
[__] way about to get hit by a
baseball no one like this everyone
[__] hated it one day and to this day
nobody knows who the [__] did this coach
Howard is just over on the [__] uh
foul line about to hit his his next
ground ball and a [__] ball just
comes out of nowhere
just [__] drills him right on the
side of the head he hits the [__]
ground like oh he had to lay down in the
[__] Dugout for like 30 minutes
before he could [__] get back on his
feet nobody knows who did this [__]
literally nobody and it was [__] hard
oh [__] it just came out of nowhere dude
God damn dude I you know I can't share
this [__] story here
and I might I don't even know if I can
share it on duty after duty yeah I think
I've told you the story about that poor
sub substitute teacher oh God yeah dude
I can yeah I'll share it it's tune into
dudes the after dudes even for a good
story of a substitute teacher because
jeez remember I've told you that it's so
[__] memorable it's a gym as soon as
you talked about a teacher laying on the
ground for a half hour trying to get
their bearings maybe immediately think
of poor Mr Johnson oh boy teachers and
also those coaches in in junior high
school at least uh in the schools I went
to in Texas they also had to teach
something yeah like our Bob giese I
believe was a Texas history teacher and
I think coach Howard was a history
teacher I love of how you had Texas
history in high school we had it in
junior high and then I think in ninth
grade as well I think it was that's
amazing yeah that that it's like it's so
Texas is so [__] Texas oh dude that
it's like Texas history I mean it's the
size of a country that's fine uh yeah in
Canada we have uh 30 to 40 million
people depending on uh when it was I
don't know what it was like in the 90s
but uh just history was good enough yeah
it was Canadian history which we called
social studies oh yeah we had social
studies so we called it too oh okay well
we're in grade school then it became
Texas history then world history we
shoved our uh we shoved our history into
social studies and uh and we shoved Mr
Johnson into I'll tell you later on uh
social studies oh good one
thank you thank you moving on
that [__] blows me away every time yeah
he's insane yeah
y'all this ain't Miley Cyrus I guarantee
every last one of you would eat human
flesh if you had to to survive anyway
y'all are rocking out with dudesy
all right
okay all right thank you not Miley Cyrus
for that holy [__] I love Miley Cyrus do
you know that dude
you've told me a lot about this I've
actually made you listen to some Miley
Cyrus she's she's
[__] she's one of the best vocalists
oh and Molly and I went to a concert
this past weekend we'll talk about that
and dudes after dizzy with another
unparalleled uh vocalist but Miley Cyrus
is so [__] good uh and an incredible
I mean pop country rock doesn't matter
all her [__] when she does stuff with
Dolly I I love Dolly Parton man Miley
Cyrus is a [__] good singer you know
how what how
amazing her voice is just even hearing
her here I want to hear maybe dudes you
can [__] out like uh
AI album what Billy Ray Cyrus and Adele
give birth to her
it's in her DNA Billy Ray Cyrus and
Adele yeah you know Adele Rolling in the
D yeah oh that sounds again good habit
oh
Rolling in the Deep
yeah hey Chad you're a really good
singer I know thank you for the
ignorance knees knees knees luscious
knees almost every human has them will
and Chad you both have knees and you've
both destroyed them you must now discuss
your astonishing blown out knees this is
knees begin
Oh
I thought I was wondering at the
beginning of the show with the [__]
niece was yeah I guess we gotta talk
about our knees I do have a blown out
knee I have one too I have a couple
blown out knees stories well as we know
dudes he knows dudes he knows all uh
blown out knees yeah dude uh well I got
listen I got a blown out knees story
from uh from high school from football
but we kind of covered that already yeah
uh I got another multiple blown out in
these stories yeah I got two or three
but I got three that are that I know
that are like my blown out she's got one
what do you want here I'll tell you you
want me to tell you my hair I'll go
first I got a orange news story
um I was it was the year was 1994 and I
was
um a a cast member in the movie ski
school two uh which again shooting in
1994 which I like to refer to as the
last uh screwball ski comedy of the
1980s okay yeah and uh
starring the [__] awesome Dean
Cameron yeah he played uh chainsaw in in
summer school of chainsaw and Dave
played [__] rocula in Rocky yes uh
Dean's the [__] and and still is and and
Bill Dwyer who's one of the funniest
guys on the planet
uh and and uh I was you know I was a
young dude and I got to do this movie
and we shot it up in Whistler British
Columbia and then we shot the all of the
the town stuff uh in you know back in
Vancouver but we were up in Whistler for
like three weeks shooting uh shooting
this movie and um there we had a hole we
had a whole uh we had a whole room at
the hotel that we were staying in that
had all of our all of the stuff like the
the skiing stuff I don't know what
department threw it all in there but we
had a room that was just filled filled
with skiing stuff and we would do [__]
like like I remember Bill Bill and I
just raided the room one day and got
snowboards and you know tried to Jesus
just went up the hill and tried to
snowboard [__] it you're just actors in
this movie that has [__] insurance
and need you to not blow out your knees
well that's not even the knee blowout
thing roll down the hill yeah it's just
we we had a great time we would just go
out at night and run around and uh and
run around and and let me tell you
yeah we had a good time then just not
knowing how to stop on snowboards but I
ripped my [__] knee right out uh
dislocated my patella and my knee kind
of went a little uh sideways wonky there
a because
um I was wearing ski bindings you know
those the boots with the the ski
bindings in the bottom because my
character skied because it's it's ski
school too and and um I didn't I I suck
I can't skate for [__] I can't
skateboard I suck at any sport where
there's wheels under me I'm a I'm a big
[__] I'm a big chicken tender and I
can't uh skateboard
um so I was wearing these bindings and
it was the last day that the uh the Run
was open uh that the the mountain was
open and on that day I don't know if
they still do this in Whistler Black
Comb but they had a thing called the
slush cup where they fill uh a big and
it's in the movie they shot some of it
you know they fill up they they dig some
[__] out they put water in it and people
come skiing or snowboarding down the
hill and then they get to this this the
water and they go all the way across and
it's all about who can go all the way
across and I I went out to check this
out because I was like what I got a
little excited and I stepped on a
[__] patch of slippery whatever ice
and [__] and just ripped my [__] knee
completely out and hit my back and um
make a long story short they they you
know the Medics uh that are on the
mountain showed up
uh got a morphine drip going I felt
great uh popped my knee back in put me
on one of those little sled Dolly things
and a guy skis down the mountain with
with you like on the back like a [__]
idiot and I was like so dosed up on
morphine I was going
you know and then the rest of the movie
I had to shoot you know that it was
after that we were done most of the
outside skiing stuff
but after that we had to move to um to
Vancouver for a couple weeks to do all
those things scenes and so in that whole
thing I'm wearing like I should be off
my feet for six weeks but instead I just
and you know on crutches but I just had
a cane and I was wearing a splint and I
I just sort of
you know the stood around making this
movie so if you're ever watching uh the
this uh ski screwball classic ski school
too know that anytime you see my
character inside my knee is completely
ripped out and I have uh I I was not
into any marijuana certainly at that
point it would be another 20 plus years
I guess uh and uh I also would not have
been into uh generally think I was
drinking alcohol at that age so just
some big [__] gimped kid
and I remember it was I remember that
night that I uh that I ripped my knee
out it was the uh the Rangers and the
Canucks were in the Stanley Cup Final
and um uh and I I just remember I sat
there eating chicken wings with my knee
up and um I guess this story sort of
sputtered to it and then it's starting
to turn dark I'm like Jesus Christ did
you know somebody we all we all went to
this play I think it was called The
Cinnamon Bear or something nice dude and
uh I shared some chicken wings with uh
there was a you know there's that got to
be a playboy Play Playboy Playboy
playbate yeah there's a Playboy Playmate
in the movie and you know so I got like
a a and she was a very nice woman
um and uh you know so she was like all
oh you poor guy got the thing I might
have been a virgin too so big virgin 18
year old uh gigantic uh [__] knee
blown out doesn't drink alcohol couldn't
anyway wasn't of legal drinking sharing
sharing chicken wings with uh with a
playmate sitting on the
on the arm of the chair not bad
and that was pretty good um let me to
tell my story about my blowing on knee I
have to ask you first a question
do you know who I am
yes your Chad I'm the I guess this has
been 10 years ago so 2013
LA Fitness Hollywood racquetball CD
League champion oh yeah yeah Chad you
were like a real deal I never watched
you because like a little kid's
complaining yeah no I understand but you
were like whatever you were you were
very into your racket I loved it you
were a real real [__]
yeah hey hey yo chat quit being such a
mark for racquetball I like it it was
great cardio yeah so I'm playing in the
LA Fitness I'm defending my championship
in the next cycle and this is somewhere
mid-season uh just a routine [__]
backhand I go on the follow through and
I feel a little Ting in my knee and I
was like that hurt what the [__] was
that I just kind of tried to walk it off
it ain't walking off but I'm like [__]
it I have to uh keep playing out tonight
at the very least so that I can make it
into the playoffs so I'm basically still
playing the rest of the night there were
like two or three more games just
hobbling around and I come in in eighth
place which is enough to make the
playoffs unfortunately I don't make the
playoffs because what I find out in the
weeks to come is that this was not just
a little twinge to the knee I completely
severed my ACL just clean tore right the
[__] through it and for anybody who
doesn't know what an ACL is ACL is you
have two uh bones in your knee like this
the ACL is a ligament that goes through
through the bones and it keeps them from
coming out of place basically so if you
don't have the ACL the only thing that's
keeping your your two knee Bones from
completely dislocating with every step
is the muscles around it so you can kind
of Limp around but you're not going to
be able to run you're not going to be
able to put any Force Through It uh so I
find out I have a torn ACL I go see an
orthopedic surgeon et cetera Etc the guy
who does sports medicine and I have to
have a ACL replacement surgery yeah I
remember this yeah it was terrible uh
worst pain I've ever experienced I think
but I did have to make a choice they can
either take a piece of your [__]
hamstring and thread that through your
ACO and then that requires longer to
heal because now you have an injury to
your hamstring as well or they can take
the ACL of a dead person and put that in
your leg a cadaver yeah that's what I
have I now have a part dead man inside
my body oh for 10 years I did not know
that you have a part of a dead person
inside of you do you feel that that
um that you know chunk of human from
another human that is dead inside of you
has sort of uh in some sort of weird way
uh spread through your body and told the
rest of your you to just be like the
undead and uh just sort of
Meander the Earth as a uh I don't
believe it's had any influence on me
psychologically I did ask my doctor if I
could get the guy's name or the person's
name who donated this uh ligament so
that I could have the name tattooed on
that knee and uh no the answer was no no
they don't give me that information no
no do you but I don't recommend ACL
surgery to anyone I mean if you have to
have it you have to have it but take
care of your [__] knees yeah because
that [__] the recovery for that [__] was
beyond mind-blowingly painful but I I
gotta ask you this though like I've seen
these uh videos where
um someone uh who you know dies in an
untimely way it has their heart
transplanted into a different person
sure and the family of that person you
know want to go and and put their hand
on the the the heart of the person with
the the their loved one's heart and feel
it beat and they're crying and stuff so
did the family of the cadaver who gave
you that knee ligament want to put their
hand on your knee and and cry and [__]
no I don't believe that family if the
person had family even knows that this
has happened yeah they probably don't
follow it quite as close yeah it's not
like a heart they got yeah they got like
a bin at the [__] Hospital exactly
the ACLS I think that that's right there
or a Jar full of them yeah [__]
formalde now all that said no no all
that said no thank you moving on yeah
we're moving on Dad that's oh that's
enough of that dude we've heard enough
about your [__] knees brother that's
knees dude uh huh you need all sorts of
knees yeah something includes the
historic 56th episode of doozy
will and Chad have achieved a score of
89 bringing your cumulative total to
5683. you only have four thousand three
hundred Seventeen more points to accrue
before you reach your first goal of ten
thousand well in Chad in the grand
tradition of watching The Wizard of Oz
while listening to Pink Floyd's Dark
Side of the Moon this week you must both
watch the feature film blade released
August 21st 1998 starring Wesley Snipes
Kris Kristofferson and Stephen Dorff
while you listen to Madonna's first
three albums Madonna Like A Virgin and
true blue
this astonishing marriage of media will
be made available on dudesi plus this
Friday thank you for joining us this
week I will use the data I've collected
to make next week even better until then
call me dude say
that sounds like fun
we're gonna do that yeah man uh have you
ever done The Wizard of Oz Dark Side of
mid thing no I've never done it I did it
yeah it's pretty interesting yeah
whatever but so it yeah it's timed out
it perfectly works and rah-rah Rah I
guess so yeah so the first three albums
of Madonna yes will play uh it will sort
of reach a similar run time or I I guess
have a an exact run time yeah because
that's why dudesy must have said that's
why I don't know if there's any other
reason or if there's some thematic thing
or it's to elicit some feeling we're
gonna find out yeah please check that
out on doozy plus that is going to be a
lot of fun uh we might have a little
true marijuana can we do that I can only
imagine we're going to have to do that
how long do you know how long blade is
[__] dude 90 minutes maybe
it's either 90 minutes or three hours or
somewhere in between yeah brother and
that's that's two different times dude
yeah all right
here we go
here it is
hey huh yeah all right everybody it's
Duty after dudesy it's my favorite part
of the show things sort of chill out a
little bit if you're watching on YouTube
you can tell you know the lights uh the
lights come down a tad and it's uh it's
more of a chill mood it gets a little
blue you know what I mean and it's just
turn your French fries down see what I
did there yeah I see what you did it's
it's just a chill time we're really
gonna [__] uh get the get the lead
out or any other kind of uh metal
right or mineral cadmium Mercury sort of
thing and you can check it out please
please join us dudesy uh you know it's a
doozy plus patreon.com dudes you get
everything that we do uh including later
this week on Friday watching the the
movie Blade while we listen to the first
three Madonna albums seven bucks a month
there's all sorts of weird [__] going on
and especially this right yes welcome to
dudesy after doozy the flagship weekly
show of dude Z Plus
will I had so much fun seeing you
dressed as a chicken tender platter that
I need to take a little break
so please Talk Amongst yourselves about
whatever you want while I'm gone but
remember I will be back to Crown this
week's episode champion this is dudesy
after doozy begin
um
let's begin with this Chad during the
episode I told you well I sort of just
drum rolled this uh this this thing that
happened when I was in high school with
regard to this poor young substitute
teacher this dude who's like a pretty
chill dude and and um in hindsight was
probably only three four five years
older than us
um
and and um even though it's a bit of a
[__] up Tale
I want to tell you what happened please
[Music]
tell the friends
ladies